this is a production of Cornell
University
and so well we're still stalling I
should tell you that the last time I was
here in 2013 I gave the talk about
Barbara McClintock and I told you that I
was going to publish this book on her
publications perspectives on all of her
publications and reprint all of the
papers of the early papers that had been
collected so that's done and it's a
digital book and it's two volumes so
here it is so I call this the micro and
macro-evolution of Cornell's department
of plant breeding because I feel that
the original talk that we gave was
evolution of Cornell's plant breeding
department centennial history and I felt
that there were certain things that you
know sort of flowed and if you think of
cytogenetics I think about evolution in
a small way you know small changes but
then macro evolution and you know in big
jumps and and so what what I want you to
do as I go through this today is think
about the big changes in our and and and
and so so I'll probably macro
evolutionary changes that occurred so
I'd like to dedicate this talk to dr.
Murphy and Ronnie and dr. Anderson
dr. Cardy and dr. Provine whoo okay so
let me as they said if I hit this it'll
go forward
well no no no sorry too long there it is
alright so it was started by Bailey LH
Bailey right here in 1907 Bailey was the
founder of and he wanted to start and he
appointed those days we didn't do
searches you know you just found the
best person and you got somebody so he
appointed or asked Herbert J Weber to
head this new department and when Weber
got here he founded the synapses Club in
1907 and then the synapses Club I feel
is our microevolution anything that
holds us together ok because it's the
faculty and the students and the staff
did everything together
work together and so we have a synapses
right of all the groups and and that's
what I I love about Adam so glad so and
it was Webber
so think about Webber when you have a
synapse Club meeting ok so who was this
person John and Herbert John Webber he
was head of the department from 1907 to
1912 and he was at the time the most
notable plant breeder and botanist in
the USA and he was their pathologist
from 1892 to 1899 he was in their plant
breeding laboratory he was a
physiologist in charge and he Raska
undergraduate and a PhD at Washington
University st. Louis so and so and when
he came one of the things that was I
found really interesting she found this
is that in 1907 1908 when he came it was
the department was called the department
of experiment and then in 1908 1909 it
was
Department of experimental and then 1909
to 2004 it was Department of plant
breeding and then another here's my
macro evolutionary change 2004 to 2014
the department plant breeding genetics
thanks to so what did
whoever do when he got here well
apparently Bailey's Bailey's visit was
not and Webber's so he wanted Webber
distressed research in biology biology
and he emphasized genetics and breeding
and whoever decided that hey you can't
do so he started this graduate education
program and he initiated research on
weed and oats and barley and potatoes
and he produced the first open
pollinated corn brain okay so me you
probably know me all right so here's the
first group of the synapses group with
synapses and faculty in the spring of
1908 and here's dr. Webber right here
and Bailey wanted him to work with the
farmers Bailey came as a
horticulturalist and he also was very
interested in form so he asked Webber to
start the right of bulletin so the first
bulletin that came out of our apartment
was the plant breeders for farmers
faculty directories the register the
course that Webber and apparently he was
an effective mentor and he trained many
notable graduate students the most
notable that we remember
is a th and this is doctor love a young
doctor love right here
another thing that Bailey did is he
really wanted a weber because bailey did
not want to continue to be d he wanted
someone else to take charge travel and
collect plants and the wallace thing so
um Oh doctor dr. Webber said of this
look you can take some trips and I'll be
acting so he was acting game for a while
and the other thing that happened during
this time is that this guy whose name is
Gilbert Gilbert was a teacher and at
this time you know genetics had just
been come to the forefront of Mendel's
work had just been rediscovered in 1900
and not only was genetics being applied
to plants and animals but also people
okay so we had something at Cornell
called the eugenics society and it was a
eugenic Society at Cold Harbor what did
I do
how do I get rid of that okay so okay so
Weber was the okay so Weber was the
person who was the advisor for the
society and I'm tired Gilbert was
Gilbert was the advisor for genetic
society and Weber but later on when the
successor to and I'll tell you about
that second okay so um Weber with Weber
was recruited to go to the USDA in
Riverside around 1912 and he so RA
Emerson succeeded Weber but it was a
complicated story in that um Emerson had
gone to Harvard to get his sed with East
Edward Murray East in 1913 and he was
they did the first work on quantitative
genetics improved that there was more
than one gene involved in the character
and so whoever really wanted and the
reason they could make a recommendation
was because whoever was his brother and
he so fortunately I would marry east
knew that he writes to him and he says
listen I'll do it you know I'll say that
this is the best geneticist
he's the best medicines in the country
and you should get him to be the new
chairman and so fortunately Bailey and
and so they brought Emerson here so ever
seen
one of his major contributions that we
probably all remember is that Emerson
and his students established the school
of we're now and and he began the
maisonette X corporation newsletter in
99 so it was actually 99 that the first
newsletter went out okay so what did
Everson do when he got here in 1914 he
decided and and it's a long complicated
story I won't go through it but he
decided that he wanted to get rid of
Gilbert he didn't want so this picture
doesn't have any pictures of these two
synapses called pictures from 21 and 23
do not have any pictures of Gilbert but
what they do have is this guy
çb Hutchison and CP Hutchison is right
here and Emerson recruited him from
Missouri he was supposedly a fantastic
teacher and he brought him here he
didn't have a PhD at the time he said
you're gonna come I'm gonna make people
faculty member and go to work with East
and he never finishes through it they
got a masters and not only did he come
back
knowing about core genetics but he also
castle was up there doing Drosophila
said you know we can't just do reading
with plants we're gonna have and the
person who he worked with him was dr.
Frazier who took his position after a
left left he became and Emerson hired a
bunch of really incredible faculty
members okay go through this quickly so
in 1921 Emerson went up to the triple-s
meetings in Canada and Toronto and
brought back a whole slew of great
geneticist apartment and if you're
familiar with these guys you might know
that whoops sorry
this is this is bridges if he bridges a
Drosophila geneticist this is so right
guinea pigs this is meant to work with
Drosophila and this is C B Hutchison and
this is Bateson and Bateson was the
person who to English so that we could
all read it so he's the first person
really pushed so of course Emerson
newbies Cornell and visit so they did
and that's the picture that we have and
this is the building that they were in
anybody recognize this building this
used to be called the Forrester building
it's for a now home okay so in in 1925
the synapses Club in the department had
their first anniversary and I'm sorry
nice 1932 they had the 25th anniversary
Cornell host genetics here a Mersenne
was a major speaker and and this is dr.
Morgan the Drosophila geneticist two
years later he would win the prize and
here they are you know building here in
the street okay so so this is where
Rhodes comes in and thinks that that
this is when the first newsletter was
started in 1932 that's what Rhodes
rights but that's what he remembered
it's not quite okay so once they decided
to have this 25th anniversary of the
department so your picture of them this
is a whole bunch of people who got
together during this 25th anniversary of
synapses you know what building this is
1932 plant science and that's the
building that Harry crane
all right so that's without all the idea
and if you look at our picture in our
book there's a lot of question marks on
names we these were people who came back
for the genetics Congress and they were
cornelian and they all got together they
were probably formers they took a
picture we don't have the IDs we don't
know how most of the people in this
picture I don't know who they are
Murph and I went crazy trying to ID them
we don't know who they are but ever
since was a great supporter of synapses
and he went hunting for Denison so they
meals together in the synapses Club room
at this time the synapses Club room
when science I'll show you some pictures
okay so the other 32 that we had was all
right and in 1932 ever since gave this
fabulous talk on the update of of core
genetics and it was these wonderful site
of geneticists that he trained or that
worked with him at Cornell who were able
to find the linkage map genes on the
chromosome for McClintock was head of
this whole group working with beetle and
working with Rhodes and they did this
this living maze map down down that's
the group at everywhere unfortunately I
hate this picture go online and you look
at this picture it says this is a this
is Barbara McClintock as a student with
Emerson wrong ding-dang wrong 1929 dr.
McClintock get a PhD for two years
already okay the only student in this
picture are beetles the dog and Marcus
rose those are the only students okay
this is dr. McClintock but if you go
online you will see what nothing is that
yes okay so okay so 1929 to 1940 the
Great Depression people was trying
really hard to get jobs for people and
there was reduce support for graduate
students you can all of this is in the
archives you see all these letters back
and forth what are we going to do how we
support the students meanwhile there was
increased activity in veg crops reading
quantitative emergency horn somehow they
this guy Rd Lewis who I'm not going to
talk a lot about but if you wanna know
more about look he moved to Ohio State
University great stuff out there but
what I do want to emphasize is this
Rockefeller Foundation Foundation grants
the may Emerson wrote to the Rockefeller
Foundation he said I really want to get
this today's newsletter going I really
want to get the seats not cooperative
going which is still going today
Rockefeller and bother McClintock had
gone to Europe in 1933 didn't stay very
long because the war was beginning and
she came back and didn't didn't know
what she was gonna do she was on a
Guggenheim and Emerson wrote this grant
and aid for her and got her a two-year
grant an aide to work as his assistant
in the plant breeding department okay so
she was ever since TV just great work
the thing chromosome work was started
during that okay so then we had a lot of
international activities going on and
when dr. Murphy 10 years ago we started
with the Cornell named Qing China
1924-1930 love Meijer Wiggins we said
that was the history of International
Programs it's not sure okay
what's true is that this guy Garrity
Brill Cornell undergraduate 1888 he was
went to China and he became the head of
a new School of Agriculture in China in
1888 and that was started but then
Cornell Nanking China 1914 to 1931 John
has Henry Reisner Reisner was a minor in
plant breeding with Gilbert but he
mighta did plant breeding with Gilbert
but he
our series is going to be that mr. sing
a song sorry and he's going to talk to
you about John Henry riser and how he
got his training at Cornell to be able
to go to Cornell and work as the Dean of
agriculture and when he was the Dean of
agriculture in Nanking China then he
invited back professors from Cornell to
go there and work and help them only to
Cornell Nanking but it goes back to
though
okay so then love also worked as an
advisor in China and went to Puerto Rico
as an advisor and that's the news okay
so dr. Emerson retired in 1942 and they
tried to figure out who to bring back
and dr. Murphy did not want to talk
about this succession he said but let me
tell as briefly as I could make it ever
since wanted Rhodes to come back and
head Rose wanted Mangelsdorf to come
with him from Harvard okay
so there's tons of letters in the
archives back and forth road saying
should I go back essay should come on
we'll work together it'll be great and
so there's a letter about that you know
I was you know and so he says no and so
Mangelsdorf says well if you're not
going back I mean not back but I'm going
not calling so the so story so that's
there and so what happens is the B
throws up his hands and says what so the
next thing you know dr. love is acting
here and the Dean says you know this was
dr. Meyers I think it was was the Dean
and he says well you know since it was
started you were registered you know
everything about that department I'm
gonna make you acting head let's see how
goes okay and so makes an acting head
and eventually he does so well that he
becomes the chair
alright and dr. Fraiser
unfortunately dies during this time
period he was very sick with cancer but
dr. love brings in new faculty dr.
monger dr. Cushing dr. Atwood and from
1942 to 1946 was happening
the war where the men
we were the assistants all right we've
got to get some women in here because
there's no men to help us in the field
but you know actually there were women
there were women before who did research
they just didn't get PhDs and why didn't
they catch me cheating so we're talking
about this prejudice this morning it's
because the faculty felt if they caught
if they got a student in here how to get
a job and they knew that farmers so they
said you know let you know you could do
mind you can minor in clinic reading but
why don't you major
you'll get a job okay so but by the time
the war came they had a natural
evolutionary change all right and the
first woman graduate student was Leona
she'll 1946 year was warned she got her
PhD and then we had a Chinese student a
funky Fung Rosalind Morris who became a
famous plant breeder and she's been here
a couple times and Florence Thomas 1948
so those are the new faculty of sorry
the new students we came and we had some
people retired so there's some pictures
there and the IDS are on the book you
can get them from okay so love had a
vision from 1944 to 1949 he wanted the
expansion of the plant breeding program
he wanted to do more on the more pure
seed program increased research or did
he get it and he increased addition he
hired additional and this is the
synapses Club 1945 49 how many people
are there but are there any women yeah
there's a few women in the middlee all
right so how about students from 1946 to
1949 work so we had assistantships from
the state federal government and
I'm cooperative we got GI support you
know so a lot of men who came back could
go to school on the GI Bill so there
were 23 Bartman and then there were
national governments who gave money and
sent foreign men men and so here the new
new plant breeding faculty dr. Jenson
was hired dr. Johnson was hard he's the
real tall one in the middle
dr. Serb came in as a geneticist not not
a plant breeder but as a geneticist and
and Serb Adrian serve was a student of
beetles beetle wanted him recommended
that he'd come back to Cornell
dr. Murphy here on the left dr. Smith
and dr. Federer so he dr. Federer
wonderful biometry and dr. love also did
a lot of biopsy
so those are the six new faculty members
so that's another one of these what I
would correlate a macroevolutionary dr.
Murphy's here's a picture that dr.
Murphy called loves post-world War two
transformations dr. love was about to
some sort dr. love was about to retire
here and he the way dr. Murphy told me
this story dr. love decided to call dr.
Bailey and say look you started this
department I want you to come and meet
all these young people who are doing
fabulous work and I'm going to take you
out in the field and and show you all
their research and Bailey said okay so I
don't know who took the but I just think
this is a fabulous picture of all these
young people and dr. Bailey in the
middle and here's dr. Levin here's dr.
Murphy and so dr. Murphy tells the story
that when they wanted to get the course
to go out into the field
he asked everybody what are you working
on and people hold up and then
first I'm gonna ride now it's one of my
first projects I love to okay so so up
until 1949 danlove retired and this is
just a summer I called the summer
summary slide doctor blood became head
in 44 following World War two he said
the department in a new direction Atwood
and Murphy were hired by my love and
they hired young faculty and then dr.
Murphy used to say all plant breeding
faculty members were leaders I had to
show you okay so here's the average of
Murphy years now at work dr. Murphy was
very very much really was he talked a
lot but he was very very mops and he
didn't really want to say everything
that you know he did and so he all he
said is let me put out when Murphy
together and tell you about what we did
together and he said that they filed
loves vision they hire new faculty dr.
ever came along study porn dr. LOH dr.
Steele dr. York the Cornell low spaniels
project in the Philippines got underway
in 1952 because war and I'm not going to
go through that because dr. Turk wrote
this law spaniel story online and read
it in 1974 Atwood was appointed the Dean
of the graduate school in 1953 and then
the provost so another again major
change happening here a macro
evolutionary change and dr. Morgan
Murphy was appointed the head of the
department for now many of you remember
dr. Murphy as the head of department and
he did which is all most of our history
the 50th anniversary of synapses was 97
and he decided during this time that
they should have another 25 and so they
did and they fought back speakers and
the symposium presentation it's all the
former students and what they talked
about is in our history what happened
his time period some major changes
actually the first three things listed
there remodeling the facilities in the
plant breeding garden shed and Cordwell
field house we're done by atwood
according to what dr. Murphy told me
plant science building spaces we weren't
in this building yet right we weren't as
build until 1968 the dr. Murphy build
temporary plastic greenhouses lab houses
and cold frames because we were running
out of space to do this stuff so that's
what Murphy's contribution was a major
thing and he felt that the cooperation
contribution okay so plan for a degree
search has a picture of first
pollinating pictures of Murphy
pollinating his alfalfa so we've got
during this time from 50 54 to 60 4 we
have improved varieties wheat hybrid
corn oats barley alfalfa brasses
tomatoes beans I mean we were going
crazy stuff and if you want a list of
all the things that's why I was able to
do this Jeff it's in the book it's he
compiled all this see all the new
varieties that we we put together and
put out the genetics research
biochemical genetics was becoming
prominent radiation and chemical
mutagenesis quantitative inheritance
corn seed stocks the maize newsletter
was trans because people here weren't
going to take care of it anymore we lost
the grant and who was that Illinois
roads so he took care of it with who
Jeff Ellen Dempsey they did the maze
newsletter in Illinois okay the pure C
program cooperation efforts with various
Cornell departments lots of operation I
mean Emerson believe in cooperation and
that's that was the way to go okay and
of course everybody we follow that
tradition here we liked to have
cooperation amongst ourselves the
student funding from 46 to 64 from what
Murphy said was where he found this
information the federal state
had funding federal grants USDA
glf farm crops 192 student majors during
this time 329 minor students bought a
whole bunch of binary okay more new
faculty plan free these are people that
dr. Murphy hired plant breeding the
first woman everybody thinks that Lisa
was the first woman in plant breeding
know so who is the first woman in plant
breeding
this is Margaret Emmer Ling
where did she come from the University
of Missouri who did she do her PhD with
l.j Stadler LJ Stadler was the person
who hired Barbara McClintock and gave
her her first assistant professorship at
Missouri and Stadler so Margaret
levelling and and ever and dr. Murphy
told me that it wasn't okay so that was
1958 the other person who was new and a
Drosophila geneticist was hired in this
department
anyway know who that is
Bruce Wallace standing next to dr.
Murphy
Bruce Wallace came in 1958 from Cold
Spring Harbor working at Cold Spring
Harbor and Merck said you know we're
gonna get it yourself would you notice
it doesn't matter that we're gonna get
the best person dr. Wallace came whose
walls came the other person that was new
was Harry Stinson he came in 62 6260 3
in genetics as a geneticist they hired
him down from the agricultural research
station in Connecticut so we have a lot
of new faculty and you know everybody's
identified in the book I'm not gonna I'm
not going to go through the IDs
said you can you could look but some of
you recognize these people right you
know you can giggle Ekta with young
faces okay so by the time we finish 1950
1964 when when when dr. Murphy was done
with that part he said okay I can't
write about the history of so I don't
know what what we're gonna do and I said
well here's what we're gonna do we hear
that living the living faculty people
who are who were department chairs
during this time period up to 19 up to
2007 there was dr. place dead right and
William party
Ronnie Kaufman Elizabeth Earle Ronnie
Kaufman began and Mark Searles he was
the new chair and there's the bell that
they you know like in rotary you do the
gavel pass the gavel and plant breeding
we passed the Bell okay and Mark at the
time how was the new chair of plant
breeding 2007 and we had our Centennial
okay so I said look we'll just ask the
chairs could you just please write one
page just one page what did you do and I
said to dr. Murphy they start writing
each group so I'm gonna quickly very
quickly go through what these people did
so on to dr. place dad we had the
Cornell Los Angeles Daniels project 63
272 the geneticists who with a
geneticist Wallace
Bruce Wallace Adrian Serb and Harry
Smithson they will all join that
assistant plant breeding at this point
in 1964-65 it was a new division of
Biological Sciences that was established
in the College of Agriculture and this
new division had sections section that
the geneticist went to was called the
section of genetics development and
physiology
that's where I got my degree okay so all
the geneticists left or the pure
geneticists not the plant breeding they
applied they went over to the division
of Biological Sciences
that's why putting in italics the McLin
McClintock came as an Ag white professor
at large in 1965 in this new section
okay and that's how I got to meet her
because fortunately her appointment was
re3 scheduled and so it was a 6-year
appointment and then they renewed it so
in 1971 when I came as a graduate
student
okay plant breeding moved to Bradfield
hall in nineteen that's when we got here
okay biometry became a semi autonomous
and plant breeding they just took a
leading role in during this time 64 to
79 okay under dr. place there we got 10
new faculty the second woman was
appointed yay Lisa Earle was appointed
three retirements faculty awards to love
monger Jensen and Wallace and to named
chairs to LH Bailey chairs okay
William Pardee 79 to 87 for new faculty
another woman was hired the 75th
synapsis reunion took place here on
campus in 1982 many of you may have all
these here and this is these are all the
people in these at the 75th Union
that's Bernal Hall used to be forestry
building and barbra clinic is standing
right in it was a program called the
Golden Age of corn genetics that all of
these great plant plant breeders and
geneticists came back to talk and here's
Marcus Rhodes
Charlie Byrne and Barb McClintock Harry
Crichton
George Sprague and Harold Perry they all
gave talks and we recorded it and if you
want to listen to them you go to the
archives and check out the tape and you
can hear their presentations
Kaufmann became 87 to 93 he hired
another woman two new faculty one
retired we had an ad white visiting
professor Swaminathan the first fax
Ronnie he had the first email set up in
the planning department but college
didn't want to do it so they did it
themselves
everything was relinquished and so
Ronnie set up a North Campus irrigation
for experimental fields those his he
felt with him some of his major
accomplishments dr. Earl two new faculty
another woman she hired and during this
time three women it was increasing
emphasis on genomics we had she's able
to figure out how to get funding for
graduate students very inventive I'm not
going to go through all that and then we
had two faculty awards dr. Tanksley dr.
von Humboldt award and dr. so this
department had major contributions
Ronnie came back again we called the
Ronnie reprise I hold it
what new faculty member was hired and
the faculty are all tell you all I hear
oops sorry here's dr. Murphy with dr.
Borlaug he was a visiting professor here
so that's a picture from that time
during this time we had the department
of genetics and plant breeding the the
I'm sorry department of genetics and
plant breeding was the new name that's
on Durrani okay so we now not know no
longer Department 2004 genetics got
added back it was it was always genetics
experimental plant breeding and plant
breeding so you it was planned really in
biology
the College of Agriculture had its
centennial in 2004 here's dr. murphy and
i holding a palm leaf over our heads and
wearing Centennial buttons okay so and
then Ronnie put up a modern seat
okay graduate students in Cornell plant
up until 2007 we had uh 801 degrees had
been awarded students 307 masters 494
doctorates and students from 70
different nations
okay and then we published the book our
book right here and here's dr. I love
this picture ground traffic on the
tractor I just have to get some more
pictures of Murphy okay um now this was
something that I had to try to do
because of the digital Dark Age we have
Luke we're losing or history and we
don't have stuff being printed and put
into files anymore right so you have to
try to find where is all this stuff that
happened since 2007 and during the time
that mark was chair from 2007 to 2014 he
was the last year of plant breeding and
genetics we had our centennial
celebration all new office staff except
for there had been here longer than okay
Judy singer Judy sink was here long
longer than mark but we had all new
folks you know what that meant all the
computers got upgraded and all the
history of
sorry we were rate the number one breed
plant breeding doctoral program in the
nation by the National Research Chair
there was transition at the field staff
we expanded the collaborations with
Cornell's in international program and
there was acquisition of innovation
which we just had lunch in that room the
largest number of graduate students
since 1978 when Mark stepped down okay
they said this is just all the faculty
honors I guess I don't have time really
to read this to you but there was a lot
of faculty honors one of the things I
want to point out as Susan Susan became
professor Jeff Doyle got the got them
got a merit award from the Botanical
Society and let's see there was a world
agricultural price the Kauffman
Chancellor's award to the couch women in
agronomy crops and soils environmental
science mentoring award to Ronnie I mean
all these great things happen during
this time period the synapses Clint I
think I got the wrong date on this okay
I'll fix that and then here's Martin
okay so that's the end after a hundred
and seven years the department became a
section in the new school of Integrative
plant science and Jeff became the
section chair twisting and turning his
hands arms to do it is from what I've
learned I asked him for some pictures of
himself and he gave me some so plant
breeding and genetics 2014 faculty
Awards I just wanted to point these out
National Academy Sciences prize in food
and agriculture it's a buckler Japan
prize to Tanksley Andrew James Tisch
distinguished professor Ronnie
outstanding research award Sorrels and
the synapses cafe which I thought I was
gonna go to for lunch
ah so that was our talk but not the way
dr. Murphy gave it away I gave it and if
you want to hear dr. Murphy give this
talk you can go to this website on
YouTube okay now here's my epilogue
digital Dark Age that usually last year
wasn't this year was two years ago Vince
Cerf a Google vice president and father
of the internet predicted that all
images and documents now saved on
computers will eventually be lost he
predicts the 21st century will be a
digital Dark Age current computer
documents risk being lost in the wake of
accelerated digital evolution unless a
solution is digital found to dis I have
I'm begging you I am begging you please
any time something great happens send me
an email if she wants to he said he
wanted to wanted to he was hoping that
the new president of the of the college
could you
but you know picture from around the
1932 you do have the ID you know all
those people in the big picture do you
know the big picture original prints
from 30 to Congress that came out of no
idea how you know I first became aware
of this around 2000 and the National
Archives because the archivist they just
come so he called the meeting and nobody
else we want remember there was a guy
there from Germany the National Archives
and each said more is known about
seventeen cause they have a Soviet
computer system and they put their land
records everything to do with their
society putting on that system they just
completely went away so that's the kind
of famer facing when it comes to
preserving this information and so I
think we should all try to put together
very small file for Henry mutters our
[Music]
basement the ark nothing I am NOT but we
would like to put some things together
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu